Hey Will Arnett, boy you got a real bright white shirt on today, kind of matched your teeth. Thanks. Do you like what I have on? Oh god, what do you call that? What do you call that? Dirty old tee? Smart!
嘿，威尔·阿奈特，天哪，你今天穿了一件特别亮的白衬衫，跟你牙齿挺配的。谢谢。你喜欢我身上的这件吗？天哪，你管那叫什么？你管那叫什么？破旧T恤？真时髦！
Smart! Smart! Smart! Smart! Smart! Smart! Smart! Smart!
时髦！时髦！时髦！时髦！时髦！时髦！时髦！时髦！
Hey guys, how are you? Listen, I feel like we just saw each other, was it last night? No, it was two nights ago. Two nights ago we saw each other and... And Will, you asked me about my car and I said I'm going to wait and tell you on Monday. I know, Sean said, I said to Sean, because we saw him the other day and his car looked different and I said, what happened to your car because you had that car that he talked about.
嘿，伙计们，你们好吗？听着，我觉得我们好像刚见过面，是昨晚吗？不，是前天。前天我们见了面，然后……威尔，你问我关于我的车的事，我说我要等周一再告诉你。我知道，肖恩说，我对肖恩说，因为我们前几天刚见过他，他的车看起来不一样，我说，你的车怎么了，因为你开过他说的那个车。
He smashed his new car with his driveway because he got it re-engineered, the gate. To close, yeah. So it's my Audi e-tron, which is my favorite car of all time. Say it one more time, clear. Let's say it one more time. God. It really is my favorite car. Well, Jason and I, obviously we have no opinion on cars.
他把新车给撞了，在车道上，因为他把大门重新设计了。让它能关上，对吧。所以那是我的奥迪e-tron，我这辈子最喜欢的车。再说一遍，清楚点。我们再说一遍。天哪。它真的是我最喜欢的车。好吧，我和杰森，显然我们对车没什么看法。
I mean, other than, you know, GMC, if you're looking for something, we should certainly love Range Rovers and Tussles and... So the garage is down. So the garage is down. We opened up the garage. There's my car and Scotty's car in there. And it's this massive horrible smell and we're like, what is it? Smells like a rotting like body or something.
我是说，除了，你知道的，GMC，如果你在找什么车的话，我们肯定也喜欢路虎揽网（Range Rovers）和Tussles还有……所以车库关了。所以车库关了。我们打开了车库。里面有我的车和斯科特的车。然后有一股巨大无比的难闻气味，我们在想，那是什么？闻起来像是一具腐烂的尸体什么的。
So we're like, we looked behind the walls, you know, we looked like outside next to the garage. Like it was weird. Anyway, I was like, well, I'm just going to get in the car and go to my appointment. So I get in the car, Scotty texts me like an hour later, he goes, ever since you left, the smell is gone. Oh my God. So you're at your appointment.
所以我们在想，我们查看了墙后，你知道的，我们查看了车库旁边外面。就像这很奇怪。不管怎样，我想，好吧，我还是上车去赴约吧。所以我上了车，大约一小时后斯科特给我发短信，他说，自从你走了，味道就没了。哦，天哪。所以你在赴约的路上。
So you were like, hang on, and you said to the guys at the Dorito factory, I got to go. What did you do? The Dorito factory. Thanks for offering the tour, but I've got to get back home. And also I'm already kind of affiliated with the gang over at Chex Mix Bugle. So I also thought it was weird that he called me and said, ever since I left, the smell is gone. But anyway, so I got back and this Audi person came because they're like on it.
所以你当时想，等等，你对多力多滋工厂的人说，我得走了。你做了什么？多力多滋工厂。谢谢你邀请我参观，但我得赶快回家。而且我也已经跟奇多圈（Chex Mix Bugle）那帮人有点合作关系了。所以我也觉得很奇怪，他打电话给我说，自从我离开后，味道就没了。不过不管怎样，我回来了，这个奥迪的人就来了，因为他们效率很高。
And they said, oh yeah, on a lot of the new electronic cars, a lot of the wires are made of soy, which is food for animals. So what happened was an animal went in, ate some of the wires and died. Really? Yeah. Was a dead animal. You know, I once found a rat living underneath the hood of the, of one of our cars here in the driveway.
他们说，哦对了，在很多新款电子车上，很多电线都是用大豆做的，那是动物的食物。所以发生的事情是，动物进去了，吃了一些电线然后死掉了。真的吗？对。是一只死动物。你知道的，我曾经在咱们车道上我们的一辆车的引擎盖底下发现过一只老鼠。
Just like nestled up in the warm pipes of the engine, a full rat's nest. Like apparently this is something that happens up at your, up at your current house. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Oh wow. Yeah. Well, that's different than eating the wires. Do you think the rat was still just traumatized by the image of Ernest Borgnein standing in
就像是依偎在发动机温暖的管道里，一个完整的鼠窝。据说明星这事在你家，在你目前的房子里也发生过。对。对，对，对。哦，哇。对。好吧，这跟咬电线可不一样。你觉得那只老鼠是不是还被欧内斯特·博格宁站在
your kitchen jerking off? Listener, I live in Ernest Borgnein's old house and Will's convinced that Ernie Borgnein was a famous masturbator. He talked about it. I don't think he did. I think he's just being mean. He said he masturbated every day and he said he used to, you know, in the opening when you walk in your house there with the stairway, he said he used to lean against the banister.
你厨房里打手枪的画面吓得有心理阴影？听众朋友们，我住在欧内斯特·博格宁的老房子里，威尔坚信厄尼·博格宁是个著名的手淫狂。他谈过这个。我不觉得他做过。我觉得他只是在刻薄。他说他每天都手淫，他说他以前，你知道的，在刚进你家门的那里有楼梯的地方，他说他以前总是靠着楼梯扶手。
Is this a true story, Will, that he's just was a notorious, that's not true. He did. He said it in an interview. I'm not making it up. What do you mean, an interview? Ernest Borgnein said it in an interview. How do you know that? I look, because I read it one time because I was looking up who masturbates more than
这是一个真实的故事吗，威尔，他只是一个臭名昭著的，这不是真的。他真的这么说过。他在一次采访中说的。我不是瞎编的。你什么意思，采访？欧内斯特·博格宁在采访中亲口说的。你怎么知道的？你看，因为我曾经读到过，当时我在查谁比
everybody. Everybody. So you're saying that's how I got a deal on this house, that it's a notorious just goo chef. You left it with Mark. That's for sure. Jackshack is the term I think that's, let's see, I'm looking it up right now. You're looking up for the article right now?
所有人都更喜欢手淫。所有人。所以你是说我买到这栋房子的便宜是因为它是个臭名昭著的精液大厨？你跟马克聊过这个。那是肯定的。我记得那个词叫Jackshack，让我想想，我正在查这个。你现在就在查那篇文章吗？
By the way. We'll wait. I guess. The Buzzfeed. Ernest Borgnein loves to masturbate. That's not true. Come on. That's not true.
顺便说一句。我们等着。我猜。Buzzfeed网站。欧内斯特·博格宁喜欢打手枪。这不是真的。得了吧。这不是真的。
Bless him. Wait, what are you talking about? The guy that healthy clearly, this guy had enough testosterone for all of us, right? Ernest Borgnein was very ferocious. 2008, he said that the secret to staying young at his old age is masturbation. Wow. And how old was he when he died? Master Bateman.
祝他好运。等等，你在说什么？这个身体这么健康的人，显然，这家伙的睾酮对我们所有人来说都足够了，对吧？欧内斯特·博格宁非常凶猛。2008年，他说保持老态年轻的秘密就是手淫。哇。他去世时多大年纪？手淫大师。
Hang on. What is he saying? It's right there. It's kind of poetic. He did live in this house for 60 years. Did he really? I don't want you to let your imagination get carried away with itself, but that's a lot of time under this roof for him.
等等。他在说什么？就在那儿。这有点诗意。他在这个房子里住了60年。真的吗？我不想让你的想象力过于脱缰，但他在这个屋檐下度过了很长的时间。
By the way, I wouldn't bring it up if he had not said it. I'll do respect to him and to his legacy, which is now a little stickier, but he's the one who said it. And he was quite open about it. Well, how old was he when he died, Ernest? Does it say there? What am I? His biographer?
顺便说一句，如果不是他自己说的话，我是不会提起的。对他的敬意以及他的传奇，虽然现在听起来有点黏糊糊的，但他才是那个亲口说出这话的人。而且他对此一直挺坦然的。好吧，厄尼去世时多大年纪？上面有写吗？把我当成他的传记作家了？
I want to say it was like 90. He was old. He lived a long time. Yeah. I want to say it was 90. Well, there you go. No, he was already 91. There.
我想说大概90岁吧。他当时年纪很大了。他活了很长时间。对。我想说是90岁。好吧，这不就得了。不，他当时已经91岁了。这呢。
How long have you guys been in that house, Jay? Six years. Seven years? How old was Ernest? Oh, my God. Granddad is asking Siri how old Ernest is. Oh, my God. He was 95.
你们在那房子里住了多久了，杰伊？六年？七年？欧内斯特多大年纪？哦，天哪。爷爷正在问Siri欧内斯特多大年纪。哦，天哪。他95岁。
Okay. 95. There you go. Yeah. So after that interview, we got four more years of snapping it off in that house before. Oh. Sean, I love watching you. I love watching you Google stuff and ask Siri stuff and I just think, do you have a robust
好吧。95岁。就是这样。对。所以在那次采访之后，我们又在那栋房子里度过了四年的疯狂时光，才……哦。肖恩，我喜欢看你。我喜欢看你用谷歌搜索和问Siri问题，我只是在想，你跟Facebook的关系也
relationship with Facebook too? Hey, Siri. You know, you don't need to hold the phone up next to your, right on your lips. You don't need to kiss Siri when you talk to her. Like that. No. Just anywhere in the room. We'll do.
很铁吗？嘿，Siri。你知道的，你不需要把手机举得那么靠近你的，就贴在你的嘴唇上。你跟她说话的时候不需要亲吻Siri。就像那样。不用。在房间里的任何地方都可以。
She can hear you. Like this. Just next to her. Like this. But I don't know. We're going to out our friend, Ernest, in here on that too. She does the same damn thing, except hers is even worse. She'll actually hold the full phone up facing the, like her nose to the glass.
她能听见你。就像这样。就在她旁边。就像这样。但我不知道，我们也要在这里把我们的朋友厄尼的秘密抖落出来了。她也有同样的毛病，除了她的更糟糕。她居然把整个手机举起来，对着，就像把鼻子贴在屏幕上一样。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's like, I don't know why she thinks she's going to get a better answer that way than just kind of just down around the hip. Sean, when we were doing the bits at Jen's house on the other night with the, with the bag, and then when I had Jen's glasses and I kept taking them off and then cleaning them.
对。对。对。对。就像是，我不知道为什么她觉得那样能得到比把手机放在腰部周围更好的答案。肖恩，前几天晚上我们在詹的家里玩游戏时，拿着那个包，然后我拿了詹的眼镜，我一直把它们拿下来然后擦拭它们。
The best. She knows she doesn't. That's a problem. She's, she's. No, she doesn't. The number of fingerprints on her glasses is, it's just remarkable as she can even see out of them. Well, they go on.
太棒了。她知道她没有。这是个问题。她，她。不，她没有。她眼镜上的指纹数量，实在是太惊人了，她居然还能透过它们看清东西。好吧，它们戴上。
They go off. They go on. They go off. You touch them and you take them off. We just kept doing bits. It was God. It was so good. That was, yeah.
它们摘下。它们戴上。它们摘下。你摸它们然后你把它们摘下来。我们一直在玩梗。天哪。真是太棒了。那是，对。
Will did one of the best bits ever, which was similar to bits I've been doing, but he acted like the purse, I don't know whose purse it was. Well, let me set it up by saying this, Sean's bit, which is great is often will be at dinner and somebody will have a handbag like on a table and Sean will come up. He'll come over, grab it, put it over, put his arm through and goes, I'm just running out to the store. Does anybody want anything? And it's really funny.
威尔做了一个有史以来最棒的梗，这跟我一直在做的一类梗有点相似，但他表现得像个钱包，我不知道那是谁的钱包。好吧，我来铺垫一下，肖恩的梗，非常棒，通常是在晚宴上，有人把手提包放在桌子上，肖恩就会走过去。他走过去，抓住它，把它挎在胳膊上，然后说，我正要跑一趟商店。有人要什么东西吗？这真的很好笑。
It never doesn't work. No, it's always funny. And then Will took it to the next level, which was actually digging in like you were looking for something that was your part. Well, I would go like this. I'd hold it like this. Then he'd come back and go, hi. Oh my God.
屡试不爽。不，总是很好笑。然后威尔把这推向了新的高度，就像你在搜寻什么东西一样，仿佛那是你的包。好吧，我会这样。我会这样拿着。然后他会走回来，说，嗨。哦，天哪。
I was just thinking about you guys. And then I pretended like look into my bag as if I'd had some stuff in there. It's really funny. It was relevant. I could watch that for nine hours. Man, he's got a real Swiss army knife with us today. This actor can be funny, dramatic, lead or supporting. I haven't seen him play a woman yet, but I bet it would be convincing.
我刚才正在想你们呢。然后我假装往包里看，就好像里面有我的东西一样。这真的很好笑。很贴切。我可以看这个看九个小时。天哪，他今天在我们这儿就像一把真正的瑞士军刀。这个演员能搞笑、能演正剧、能演主角或配角。我还没见过他演女人，但我敢打赌那也会很有说服力。
He's got all the nominations you could want, all the respect and admiration possible, but even more importantly, a successful marriage and two great kids. On the sad side, he can't swim, can't ride a bike or sleep laying down. But we're going to cover all of that next with our very special guest, one of my heroes, Massachusetts own and Nancy's guy, Mr. Stephen John Correll. Hey guys. Steve. Hi, Steve.
他拥有你所能想要的一切提名、所有的尊重和钦佩，但更重要的是，有一段美满的婚姻和两个好孩子。悲伤的是，他不会游泳，不会骑自行车，也不能平躺着睡觉。但接下来我们将跟我们非常特别的嘉宾讨论所有这些，他是我的偶像之一，来自马萨诸塞州的小伙子，南希的男人，斯蒂芬·约翰·卡瑞尔先生。嘿，伙计们。史蒂夫。嗨，史蒂夫。
Steve knows Jen. Steve, have you ever seen Jen do that I'm new to technology bit where she just presses it up against her nose and talks to Siri like that's going to make it all happen. I haven't seen that. No. Thank you for coming. Thanks, Steve. Thanks for having me.
史蒂夫认识詹。史蒂夫，你见过詹做那种“我刚接触科技”的梗吗？就是她把手机紧贴着鼻子跟Siri说话，好像这样就能让一切发生一样。我没见过。没有。谢谢你们的到来。谢谢你，史蒂夫。谢谢邀请我。
Wonderful. Our next guest now, probably in your defense, you're busy being professional in your dressing room, learning your lines. You're not mixing. Oh, you're on the set right now. Well, when he was working with Jen there on the morning show, he's not around her when she's asking Siri about the non-important question in the world. He's preparing.
太棒了。我们的下一位嘉宾，也许为了公平起见，你当时正忙着在化妆间里展现专业精神、背台词。你没有在闲聊。哦，你现在正在片场。好吧，当他在早间秀上跟詹合作时，当她问Siri世界上那些不重要的问题时，他可不在她身边。他在准备。
Yeah, please. I'm always preparing. Sure. Sure. Are you at work right now, Steve? Are you preparing now? No. I'm not at work ever.
对，请吧。我一直在准备。当然。当然。史蒂夫，你现在在工作吗？你现在在准备吗？没有。我从来不在工作。
Would that be great if you were sitting on the can right now, if you just panned down right now? He's just... I'm done. He's working on something else. Yeah. The only place we could catch him for a solid hour. Steve Correll, good to see you.
如果你现在正坐在马桶上，如果镜头现在摇下去，那不是很棒吗？他只是……我结束了。他在忙别的。是的。我们唯一能抓到他整整一个小时的地方。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，很高兴见到你。
It's good to see you, man. I'm so glad you're here. It's so good to see you guys. How great is that? Steve Correll is on the show, everybody. Pull over, turn your car off. I'm just... Steve, I'm just sitting here looking, because I'm just a fan.
很高兴见到你，伙计。我很高兴你来到这里。很高兴见到你们。这太棒了吧？史蒂夫·卡瑞尔上节目了，大家。把车靠边停下，熄火。我只是……史蒂夫，我只是坐在这里看着，因为我只是个粉丝。
I'm just a... Who is that? I'm an old school... You just call me a fan. Yeah, I am. I'm soaking it in. I just think you're great. When you died on the morning show, spoiler alert, I was completely crushed, like I was
我只是一个……那是谁？我是一个老派的……你刚才叫我粉丝。对，我是。我正在沉浸其中。我只是觉得你太棒了。当你在早间秀里死掉的时候，剧透警告，我彻底崩溃了，就像我
so invested. Okay. You weren't supposed to be crushed by my character. I was, though, because you were coming around. Your character was coming around. You know, a lot of people haven't finished the first season, John. The second season. The first second season, sorry.
投入了太多的感情。好吧。你不该为我的角色崩溃的。但我确实崩溃了，因为你当时正在转变。你的角色正在转变。你知道的，很多人还没看完第一季，约翰。第二季。第一第二季，抱歉。
Well, it was a true spoiler for me right there. I was galloping towards that episode, but I can go ahead and hop that now, I guess. Well, News Flash, it came out 19 years ago. Well, but, you know, but I like to wait until a few build up, and then I just binge them all. All right. What about a rest of development? Sean, favorite episode?
好吧，对我来说这真是一个剧透。我正全速向那一集冲刺，但我想现在我可以跳过那一集了。好吧，爆炸新闻，那是19年前播出的。好吧，但是，你知道，但我喜欢等到攒了几集之后，然后一口气全看完。好吧？发展受阻怎么样？肖恩，最喜欢哪一集？
Son of a bitch. He's never seen it, Steve. He's never seen it. He's never seen it. Not the one. He's never seen it. I'm not. It's not my list.
狗娘养的。他没看过，史蒂夫。他从没看过。他从没看过。不是那一集。他没看过。我没有。那不在我的名单上。
Let's get into the really hard pressing journalistic questions I've got from you. Care of Wikipedia. Hold, please. Wait, Steve, where are we catching you? Are you LA? Are you East Coast? I'm East Coast. I'm back in Massachusetts right now.
让我们来谈谈我从维基百科上为你准备的那些真正尖锐的八卦新闻吧。请保持通话。等等，史蒂夫，我们在哪里连线你？你在洛杉矶？还是在东海岸？我在东海岸。我现在回马萨诸塞州了。
Oh. Now, are you, now, I remember years ago, you were saying that at one point that you were going to potentially kind of eventually move back there full time. Have you done that? We'll sort of halftime at this, probably six and six. I think that's how we're going to do it. Are you off of work right now? I am, yeah.
哦。那么，你，现在，我记得几年前，你曾说过在某个时候你可能会最终搬回那里常住。你这么做了吗？我们算是半职在这儿，大概六个月对六个月吧。我想我们打算这么做。你现在不用工作吗？是的，我在休假。
Okay. So you were born in Massachusetts, spent some time there. Is this where potentially you got interested in acting slash comedy? If so, was it because you were funny and or outgoing as a kid? Did it all start happening for you there? Or was it later? I wasn't outgoing as a kid. I was pretty shy.
好吧。所以你出生在马萨诸塞州，在那里度过了一些时间。你对表演或喜剧的兴趣就是在那儿萌芽的吗？如果是的话，是因为你小时候是个搞笑或者外向的孩子吗？这一切是从那里开始的吗？还是后来才开始的？我小时候并不外向。我相当害羞。
I liked to do theater, but it wasn't specifically my thing. I did a lot of other stuff, but it was fun. But I wouldn't allow myself to ever think of it as a career or a potential career. It just seemed like. Because I remember being in Chicago, you were like, everybody was like, Steve Carell, you were the god of Second City there. It was like, just the fact that you went through there in Chicago, everybody was like, just thought you hung the moon as did I.
我喜欢演戏剧，但那并不是我专门的目标。我做过很多其他的事情，但这很有趣。但我绝不允许自己把它当成一份事业或潜在的事业来考虑。它看起来只是……因为我记得在芝加哥的时候，你就像是，每个人都说，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，你是芝加哥第二城（Second City）的神。就像是，仅仅因为你在芝加哥经历过那里，每个人都觉得，就觉得你无所不能，我也是。
What is it with, what is it? What is the difference between being shy? Because I think I'm kind of shy, but I'm, I don't mind being, for instance, I'm very shy to like make a toast or something like that. But I am not shy when the camera's on and I get to play a character or something. Are you similar in that because it's hard to correlate or to reconcile being shy and also willing to be in front of the camera? How did that work for you?
这到底是是怎么回事？害羞和不害羞的区别是什么？因为我觉得我有点害羞，但我，我不介意，比如，我很害羞去做祝酒之类的。但当镜头开机，我要扮演一个角色的时候，我一点也不害羞。你也是这样吗，因为很难把害羞和愿意出现在镜头前这两件事联系或调和起来？这对我来说是怎么运作的？
I think it's the same for me because I feel like you can hide behind a character. You can hide behind a performance and dialogue. You can even hide in a way behind improvisation because it's, you know, you're kind of stepping outside of yourself in a way. But I think a lot of people are the same way. You know, when, you know, at my wedding, I got so shy at my wedding because all of the focus is on you and your, you know, and your wife. And it's weird because it's just you.
我觉得对我来说也是一样的，因为我觉得你可以藏在一个角色背后。你可以藏在表演和台词后面。你甚至可以在某种程度上藏在即兴表演后面，因为，你知道的，你在某种程度上超越了自我。但我认为很多人也是这样。你知道，在，你知道的，在我的婚礼上，我变得非常害羞，因为所有的焦点都在你和你，你知道的，还有你妻子身上。这很奇怪，因为只有你们两个。
There's nothing, there's nothing else. Did you cry at your wedding? I didn't cry at my wedding. I was sweating a lot, but I didn't cry. So the body was crying. My, well, it was, we were married here in Massachusetts. I was super human, super hot that day. And I remember I was pouring sweat and then Nancy appeared at, you know, down the aisle
没有别的，什么都没有。你在婚礼上哭了吗？我在婚礼上没哭。我出了很多汗，但我没哭。所以我的身体在哭。我，嗯，那是，我们在马萨诸塞州结的婚。那天天气超级好，超级热。我记得我当时大汗淋漓，然后南希在，你知道的，走道那头出现了，
and the sweat dried up and I would like my nerves completely went away. It was the craziest thing. Just seeing her as she started to walk down the aisle, I thought, oh man, this is like, did you dance with her? Definitely. I continued to dance with her to this very day. I love that. I did not.
然后汗水就干了，我的紧张感完全消失了。这真是太疯狂了。一看到她开始沿着走道走过来，我就想，哦天哪，这就像是……你跟她跳舞了吗？当然。直到今天我依然在跟她跳舞。我喜欢这样。我没有。
You know, because I, going back to the shy thing, I think a lot of the mis, there's a big misconception. I think Jason was touching on this. If you're an actor, people are like, well, being shy is just an excuse. You just don't want to talk. Like how could you be scared to be, speak in front of a large group of people? But it is, it's, it's, if something's not written for you or you can't cultivate a character, it's one of the reasons we're actors is because it is too nerve wracking unless that's done
你知道的，因为我，回到害羞这个话题，我觉得有很多误解，有一个很大的误解。我想杰森刚才提到了这一点。如果你是一个演员，人们会觉得，好吧，害羞只是一个借口。你只是不想说话。你怎么会害怕在众人面前说话呢？但确实是这样，如果有些东西不是为你写的，或者你无法塑造一个角色，这就是我们成为演员的原因之一，因为这太让人神经紧张了，除非这些已经为你准备好了。
for you. But Willie doesn't have a problem with that. You're never shy away from, you know, making a toast for someone in a very sincere, genuine way, but also being very funny. Like you don't, you don't have an allergy to a spotlight. I, I, I get, I get, I get small. No, I, yeah, but I might have like a condition. Yeah.
但威尔在这方面没有问题。你从不羞于为某人做一次非常真诚、发自内心的祝酒，而且还非常有趣。就像你，你对聚光灯没有过敏反应。我，我，我，我变得很渺小。不，我，是的，但我可能有什么毛病。对。
There's a chance. I'm glad you said it. Yeah. Let's, let's build on that. No, well, let's not. I, I was thinking about reminding me of Steve's, you know, John Glazer. Oh yeah. Yeah.
很有可能。我很高兴你这么说。对。让我们，让我们在这个话题上继续。不，好吧，我们还是别了。我刚才在想，让我想起了史蒂夫的，你知道的，约翰·格拉瑟。哦，对。对。
I knew him for a second. Jason, you remember Glazer? Yeah. Yeah. I don't know, I didn't get to miss cause we were working, but I remember Amy went and a bunch of, and Glazer was giving a speech at his own wedding and he started to cry. He started to tear up and John Benjamin and David Cross started going, cry, cry, cry. That'll make you feel more comfortable.
我认识他一会儿。杰森，你还记得格拉瑟吗？对。对。我不知道，我没能错过，因为我们在工作，但我记得艾米去了，还有一堆人，格拉瑟在他自己的婚礼上致辞，他开始哭了。他开始眼含泪水，然后约翰·贝金杰和大卫·克罗斯开始喊，哭，哭，哭。那会让你感觉更舒服。
I don't know. I haven't thought about that in 15, 20 years. Steve, again, in this incredible, I don't know if you guys have ever heard of Wikipedia, but it's such a source. It says here, were you also in Massachusetts when you were the disc jockey at W-Dub, both the handle Sapphire, Steve Carell? No, that was in college. Okay.
我不知道。我15、20年没想过这事了。史蒂夫，再次提到这本不可思议的——我不知道你们有没有听说过维基百科，但它真是个宝库。这里写着，当你在W-Dub电台当DJ、化名为Sapphire史蒂夫·卡瑞尔时，你也在马萨诸塞州吗？不，那是在大学里。好吧。
I went to school. How did we get Sapphire? Well, the guy, you know, you have to intern under somebody when you first joined the college radio station. Which was where? Where, where were you for college? I went to Denison University in Ohio and listen, that's a family name. My son's name is, my youngest son's name is, is Denison, Alexander Denison, and we call
我去上学了。我们怎么会有“Sapphire”这个名字的？嗯，那个家伙，你知道的，当你刚加入大学广播电台时，你必须在某个人手下实习。那是哪里？你上大学是在哪里？我去了俄亥俄州的丹尼森大学，听着，那是个家族姓氏。我儿子的名字是，我小儿子的名字是，丹尼森，亚历山大·丹尼森，我们叫
him Denny. Yeah. Oh, I didn't know that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Anyway, sorry. No, no. I was interning under this guy who called himself Diamond Doug McKenney and so the first time he allowed me on the air.
他丹尼（Denny）。哦，我不知道这个。对，对，对。不管怎样，抱歉。不，不。我当时在这个自称道格·麦金尼钻石（Diamond Doug McKenney）的家伙手下实习，所以他第一次允许我上星。
He sounds very good. I just was kind of blowing him some shit and I said, this is the Sapphire Steve Carell. And then he didn't really, he didn't think it was that funny. Wait, Steve, what kind of music did you play when you DJ'd? Mostly Stairway to Heaven. Yeah. Anything really long, really long songs because I had, you know, as a freshman too, you get the worst shifts.
他听起来很棒。我当时只是在跟他开玩笑，我说，这是蓝宝石史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Sapphire Steve Carell）。然后他其实并没有，他觉得这没那么好笑。等等，史蒂夫，你当DJ时放什么音乐？大多是《通往天堂的阶梯》（Stairway to Heaven）。对。任何非常长的歌，非常长的歌，因为我有，你知道的，作为一个大一新生，你总是排到最烂的班次。
So I was on from like five to seven in the morning. Okay. And we will be right back. Hey, smartlist listener. You're supported by Lost Debate. Today's polarized media landscape gives people a false choice, stay in a partisan bubble that never challenges you to think or embrace the online outrage cycle. But you can choose something even better.
所以我得从早晨五点工作到七点。好吧。我们马上回来。嘿，SmartLess的听众们。本节目由《Lost Debate》赞助支持。当今两极分化的媒体环境给人们提供了一个虚假的选择，要么留在从来不挑战你思考的党派温室里，要么拥抱网络愤怒的循环。但你可以选择更好的东西。
You can join the Lost Debate. It's a podcast for anyone who wants to escape their echo chamber and engage with ideas from across the spectrum with the kind of good faith discussions we need more of as a society. Lost Debate is hosted by Ravi Gupta, a former Obama staffer and school principal and superintendent who spent years on the front lines of America's political battles working to preserve our democracy. And also hosted by Ricky Schlatt, a Gen Z New York Post columnist and libertarian fighting to protect free speech for her generation and beyond. Together, they cover all the latest news arguments, ideas and trends with balance and nuance.
你可以加入《Lost Debate》。这是一个播客，适合任何想要逃离回音室、与来自不同光谱的观点进行交流的人，采用我们作为一个社会更加需要的真诚讨论方式。由拉维·古普塔（Ravi Gupta）主持，他曾是奥巴马的工作人员、学校校长和总学区长，多年来一直在美国政治斗争的前线致力于维护我们的民主。同时由瑞奇·施拉特（Ricky Schlatt）主持，她是一位Z世代的《纽约平台》专栏作家和自由主义者，致力于为她这一代人及以后的人保护言论自由。他们一起以平衡和细致的态度涵盖了所有的最新新闻、争论、观点和趋势。
They have constructive discussions that sound less like hot takes for clicks and more like a conversation between real people trying to find middle ground. So come join the conversation. New episodes of Lost Debate drop twice a week every Tuesday and Thursday. Find Lost Debate on Amazon, Spotify, Apple, YouTube or wherever you get your shows. This episode of SmartList is brought to you in part by Thuma. I've moved so many times in my life. We all have.
他们进行的建设性讨论听起来不像是为了点击量而发表的激烈言论，更像是真实人们之间试图寻找共同点的对话。快来加入这场对话吧。《Lost Debate》的新剧集每周二和周四更新两次。在亚马逊、Spotify、Apple、YouTube或任何你收听节目的地方寻找《Lost Debate》。SmartLess的这一集部分由Thuma赞助。我一生中搬过很多次家。我们都搬过。
We all know the vibe and we have all put together and disassembled beds. And we all know that that can be a pain in the rear end. So how do we get away from doing that? How can we get a bed that is a great bed that is also not a real pain to put together? Introducing the bed by Thuma handcrafted from eco-friendly high quality upcycled wood. You'll find beautiful unique variations in the natural grain. The minimalist design featuring Japanese joinery helps elevate any space. It's super supportive for your mattress, breathable and made to naturally minimize noise and create
我们都懂这种感觉，我们都组装和拆卸过床。我们都知道那可能是一件让人头疼的事。那么我们如何摆脱这种困扰呢？我们怎么能买到一张既是一张好床，又不会在组装时让人头疼的床呢？隆重推出Thuma的床，采用环保、高质量的升级再造木材手工制作。你会发现天然纹理中美丽而独特的变体。极简主义的设计采用日本细木工工艺，有助于提升任何空间。它对你的床垫有极好的支撑，透气，并且天然地减少噪音并创造
space. The perfect platform bed frame just got better. You can now customize the bed by choosing between their original pillow board or their new solid wood headboard. Thuma practices an intentional less is more designed philosophy for the bedroom with clean lines, subtle curves and lifestyle enhancing details. Thuma proves that simplicity is the truest form of sophistication. So it's tough to put a bed together, but with Thuma it's not.
空间。完美的平板床架变得更好了。你现在可以通过在他们原来的靠枕板或新的实木床头板之间进行选择来定制床。Thuma在卧室设计上贯彻了有意为之的“少即是多”的哲学，拥有干净的线条、微妙的曲线和提升生活品质的细节。Thuma证明了简单是复杂的最高形式。所以组装一张床很难，但有了Thuma就不难了。
You can put it together by yourself. It looks amazing. It doesn't squeak. It's just really easy to do and looks amazing. Create that feeling of checking into your favorite boutique hotel suite, but at home with The Bed by Thuma. And now go to Thuma.co slash smartlist to receive a $25 credit toward your purchase of The Bed plus free shipping in the continental US.
你可以自己把它组装起来。它看起来棒极了。它不会吱呀作响。真的很容易操作，而且看起来棒极了。在家中创造入住你最喜欢的精品酒店套房的感觉，只需选择Thuma的床。现在前往Thuma.co/smartlist即可获得25美元的购买床铺抵用券，并在美国大陆境内享受免运费。
Go to Thuma.co slash smartlist that's T-H-U-M-A.co slash smartlist for a $25 credit. Our next partner is Athletic Greens. I take AG1 by Athletic Greens literally every day. I gave AG1 a try, I don't know, two years ago maybe. I wanted better gut health. I wanted more energy. I wanted a simple way to take vitamins and minerals that were important to my body. I didn't want to have to take all these supplements.
前往Thuma.co/smartlist，即T-H-U-M-A.co/smartlist获取25美元的抵用券。我们的下一个合作伙伴是Athletic Greens。我 literalmente 每天都喝Athletic Greens的AG1。我试用AG1大概是，我不知道，两年前吧。我想要更好的肠道健康。我想要更多的精力。我想要一种简单的方法来摄取对我身体重要的维生素和矿物质。我不想吃所有这些补充剂。
I wanted one place and AG1 is that place. I put it in the thing, I shake the thing, I down the thing and it's so good for my body and it tastes great. This is the best option for easy optimal nutrition out there. You take one scoop of AG1 and you're absorbing 75 high quality vitamins, minerals, whole foods, source, superfoods, probiotics and adaptogens to help you start your day right. This blend of ingredients supports your gut health, your nervous system, your immune system, your energy, recovery, focus and aging.
我想要一个地方，而AG1就是那个地方。我把它倒进杯子里，摇一摇杯子，然后一饮而尽，这对我的身体太好了，而且味道很棒。这是市面上获取简单、最佳营养的最佳选择。你只需要一勺AG1，就能吸收75种高质量的维生素、矿物质、全食物来源的超级食物、益生菌和适应原，帮助你开启美好的一天。这种成分组合支持你的肠道健康、神经系统、免疫系统、能量、恢复、专注和抗衰老。
You know what I love most about it? You can mix it with water when you're traveling. You can put it in a smoothie like with all the other stuff that you make your smoothies with and it tastes great. It tastes great any way you want to roll. I mean it's the healthiest way to start your day for me and I know it will be for you too. Right now it's time to reclaim your health and arm your body with convenient daily nutrition. It's just one scoop of AG1 and a cup of water every day.
你知道我最喜欢它什么吗？旅行时你可以把它和水混在一起。你可以把它放进冰沙里，就像你制作冰沙时放的所有其他东西一样，而且味道很好。无论你怎么喝，味道都很好。对我和我来说，这是开启一天最健康的方式，我知道对你也是如此。现在是时候重拾你的健康，用方便的日常营养武装你的身体了。每天只需一勺AG1和一杯水。
You don't need a million different pills and supplements to look out for your health. Athletic Greens is going to give you a free one year supply of immune supporting vitamin D and five free travel packs with your first purchase. Go to athleticgreens.com slash smartlist to give AG1 a try. That's athleticgreens.com slash smartlist. Check it out. And now back to the show. So Steve, so walk me through a little bit.
你不需要一百万种不同的药丸和补充剂来关注你的健康。Athletic Greens将在你首次购买时免费提供一年份支持免疫的维生素D和五包免费旅行装。访问athleticgreens.com/smartlist来尝试AG1。网址是athleticgreens.com/smartlist。快去看看吧。现在回到节目中。那么史蒂夫，跟我聊聊你的经历吧。
You're from sort of the Boston area and you go to Denison and then what's the move? How do you end up doing going to Chicago and getting into Second City? Like because it's a question that kind of comes up with people in comedy, especially people who go through Second City. What was that? What was that moment for you? Like, yeah, I got to go to Chicago or that's for me or... Well, I was working as a postal carrier in Massachusetts.
你来自波士顿地区，然后去了丹尼森，接着下一步是什么？你是怎么去芝加哥并加入第二城的？因为这是一个在喜剧界的人经常会被问到的问题，特别是那些经历过第二城的人。那是怎样的？对你来说那个时刻是怎样的？比如，是的，我得去芝加哥，或者那是属于我的……嗯，我当时在马萨诸塞州做邮递员。
Yeah, really? You left because you were too slow or got fired because you were too slow? I was terrible. Well, I left because two buddies of mine from college said, hey, let's go to Chicago and we're going to start an educational theater company. This is post-college. This is post-college. I had gone back to Massachusetts living with my folks, got a job as a mail carrier.
真的吗？你离开是因为你太慢了还是因为太慢被解雇了？我太糟糕了。嗯，我离开是因为我大学里的两个好朋友说，嘿，我们去芝加哥吧，我们要成立一家教育戏剧公司。这是大学毕业后。这是大学毕业后。我回到马萨诸塞州和父母住在一起，找了一份邮政快递员的工作。
Wow. I was trying to put some money away to make some sort of move eventually. I didn't know where. And they said, let's, you know, we're going to move to Chicago, get an apartment and just try our hand at theater on the side. We'll create this educational theater company, we'll make some money and perform for kids on the side and I was in and that's how it happened. But you go to Chicago to do this educational theater, which by the way, pre-Yan, and then
哇。我当时在努力存点钱，以便最终搬家。我不知道去哪儿。他们说，我们要搬到芝加哥去，租个公寓，顺便在业余时间尝试一下戏剧。我们将成立这家教育戏剧公司，我们可以赚点钱，业余时间为孩子们表演，我加入了，事情就是这样发生的。但你去芝加哥是为了做这个教育戏剧，顺便说一句，在延恩之前，然后
you get there. Fuck me, man. I mean, I'm still stuck on the money-earning career as a postal worker and then an improv artist. If you and I had been friends in high school and you had said to me, hey, I'm going with those other guys, I would have, you wouldn't have made a fucking dime in your life because you would have never left. I would have been like, are you out of your fucking mind?
你到了那儿。真他妈的，伙计。我的意思是，我还卡在靠邮政工人的职业赚钱，然后是即兴表演艺术家。如果你和我高中时是朋友，而你对我说，嘿，我要跟那几个家伙一起去，你这辈子连他妈的一毛钱也赚不到，因为你根本就不会离开。我会觉得，你他妈疯了吗？
You're not going to fucking Chicago. I got to do fucking, Steve, get a fucking grip. Hey, Carell. What the fuck did you do when fucking Carell wants to do, shut the fuck up, dude. So you're lucky you did go because it worked out well. But how did you go to go do that and then did that fall apart and you just saw a sign for Second City like out of a movie, like, hey, there's Michael Hulling. Well, that was always the ultimate plan.
你才不去他妈的芝加哥呢。我得去——操，史蒂夫，振作点他妈的。嘿，卡瑞尔。卡瑞尔他妈的想去的时候你干了什么，闭上你他妈的嘴，老兄。所以你很幸运你去了，因为结果很好。但你是怎么去干那个的，然后那个黄了，你就看到一个像电影里那样的第二城的招牌，就像，嘿，那是迈克尔·霍林。嗯，那一直是终极计划。
It was. Yeah, for sure. I mean, I really wanted to go to Chicago to do improv and to try to at least take classes at Second City and to do plays. At that point, I wasn't thinking specifically comedy because I didn't, I didn't think I was that funny, you know, that, that really didn't seem like my forte. Well, that makes sense because your, your ability, and this is why I said right at the beginning that I'm such a fan, you know, during these last couple weird years of, of
是的。绝对是的。我的意思是，我真的很想去芝加哥做即兴表演，至少尝试在第二城上课并演话剧。当时我并没有具体考虑喜剧，因为我当时并不觉得自己那么搞笑，你知道的，那真的不像是我的强项。嗯，这说得通，因为你的能力，这就是为什么我一开始就说我是个大粉丝，你知道的，在这几年全球灾难的奇怪日子里，我看了《办公室》的所有剧集，我对你的所作所为更加惊叹了。这很大程度上是因为你是一个如此出色的演员。
this worldwide disaster, I've watched all of the office and I've just even further in awe of what you do. And there's so much of it is because you're such a great actor. Yeah. A lot of people who are really funny, but you are, you are truly both in such a profound way. And yeah, that's, that's really true. Yeah.
是的。很多人非常搞笑，但你，你在如此深刻的程度上两者兼备。是的，这真的，真的很对。是的。
Yeah. Well, there it is guys. Steve Corral, Dime Sapphire Steve and we've had a great time. It is true. But it's true. Your humor always comes from the, from the, from the, from the, the depth of the character you have like the stones to pull off. Your Michael Scott, there was so much pathos there.
好吧，各位，这就是了。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，蓝宝石史蒂夫，我们度过了一段美好的时光。确实如此。但这是真的。你的幽默总是来自于，来自于，来自于，来自于你有胆量展现的角色深度。你的迈克尔·斯科特，里面有那么多的悲情。
There was so much of it coming from a real place in such a way that I think connected with people. And certainly, I don't know, I just loved it. And I think that you're very believable as a, you're just a great actor. I don't know. And did, I was going to ask you like, was there any nervousness or apprehension to, to, to take over the, the, the office after the British office had so much critical acclaim and was, was, you know, talked about and buzzy and all this stuff.
有那么多来自真实地方的东西，以至于我认为它能与人们产生共鸣。当然，我不知道，我就是很喜欢。而且我认为你作为一个，你真的是个伟大的演员，非常可信。我不知道。我本来想问你，接手英国版《办公室》获得那么多好评、讨论和关注的《办公室》后，你是否有任何紧张或忧虑。
But I would imagine that you found comfort in the fact that what Ricky Gervais does so well is play that character, he played that comfort or that character with so much sort of melancholy and, and drama that in other words, it wasn't funny to him at all. You know, no one's, he'd kill somebody if he heard them laughing at him. So did, did you think, well, oh, I can play that kind of funny, like no winking. I got it. Well, that's what I find funny in general is, you know, a character in a comedy doesn't know they're in a comedy.
但我猜你会从瑞奇·吉尔维斯做得非常好的事情中找到安慰，那就是扮演那个角色，他带着如此多的忧郁和戏剧性来扮演那种舒适感或那个角色，换句话说，对他来说这根本一点也不好笑。你知道，如果他听到有人嘲笑他，他会杀了他。所以，你当时想，哦，我可以扮演那种好笑的，就像不眨眼。我懂了。嗯，这正是我通常觉得好笑的地方，你知道的，喜剧里的角色并不知道自己身处喜剧中。
Right. And the same goes for a drama. You know, you don't, you don't know what the circumstances are of your story, your own story is, you know, as a character. Yeah. So, so when crazy people don't know, they're crazy. Exactly. You know, drunk people don't really know they're as drunk as they are.
对。正剧也是如此。你知道，作为一个角色，你并不知道你的故事，你自己的故事的环境是什么。是的。所以，当疯子不知道自己是疯子时。正是如此。你知道的，喝醉的人并不知道自己有多醉。
So you kind of play against it, you know, and, and I, and I think the same goes for comedy. It's really, really off-putting to me whenever I see someone, like you said, winking at the camera or kind of acknowledging how funny they are being in the moment. That always, that always pulls me out. I would always think about somebody like Peter Sellers, who did the most outrageously broad characters and never let on that he thought he was doing anything even remotely funny. Right.
所以你得反着来演，你知道的，而且，我认为喜剧也是如此。每当我看到有人像你说的，对镜头眨眼，或者在当下表现出自己有多搞笑时，我都会觉得非常非常倒胃口。那总是把我拉出戏。我总是会想到像彼得·塞勒斯这样的人，他做了最离谱、最宽泛的角色，却从不透露他觉得自己做了哪怕有一点点好笑的事情。对。
That anybody was watching him, you know, that there's no audience. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. But I think that's, you guys do exactly that same thing. I mean, I think I'm, I'm fans of all of yours for that exact reason, you know, you never see it. You never, you never see sort of pandering or winking at an audience.
没有人看着他，你知道的，那里没有观众。对。没错。是的。但我觉得，你们做的事完全是一样的。我的意思是，我认为我是你们所有人的粉丝，正是出于这个确切的原因，你知道的，你从来看不到。你从来看不到那种迎合或对观众眨眼。
Well, Jason has a lot of winking off camera, but, but I will say, and it's a little, it's alarming. It's unsettling, but Steve, and I want to sort of, because I know that Jason sort of brought up and I'd heard, and I think that you've said before, like you, you actually, of course you knew about Ricky's office, the UK version, but that you weren't, you didn't look at, you didn't want to see it because you wanted to do your own thing, which I think is really fabulous. Is that true?
好吧，杰森在镜头外有很多眨眼，但是，我要说的是，这有点，这有点让人担忧。这让人不安，但史蒂夫，我想，因为我知道杰森提起了这个，我听说过，而且我想你以前也说过，你当然知道瑞奇的英国版《办公室》，但你没有看，你不想看，因为你想做你自己的事，我觉得这真的很棒。这是真的吗？
Did you not see in the office before you? I've never seen it. I've never seen the UK version. No way. Still to this day. No, not to this day. Which makes total sense. And I think it's really such an even, even a further to testament to your, you know,
你在出演《办公室》之前真的没看过吗？我从来没看过。我从来没看过英国版。绝不可能。直到今天也没有。不，直到今天也没有。这就完全说得通了。而且我认为这真的更能证明你的，你知道的，
your talent and, and, you know, we were such big fans of the UK version and we were, you know, and we're friends and Ricky's a very good friend and I am able to like each of them for very different reasons. And I love both versions and honestly, I just think that I want to once and for all just sort of like put that out there that you, not only did you not watch it, you've never watched it, which is phenomenal. Well, I watched, well, I'll take that back. I watched just for a frame of reference.
你的才华，而且，你知道的，我们曾是英国版的超级粉丝，我们是，你知道的，我们是朋友，瑞奇是一个非常好的朋友，我能够出于非常不同的原因喜欢他们每一个。我两个版本都喜欢，老实说，我只是想一劳永逸地把这一点说出来，你不仅没看过，而且你从没看过，这太惊人了。好吧，我看了，好吧，我收回刚才的话。我为了找个参考框架看了。
I watched about maybe three minutes of an episode before I auditioned and I knew instantly that I couldn't watch it because he was too good because if I, if I watched any more, I would want to just do what he was doing. Right. I understand. Really. I was hilarious. Do you want to hear, you want to hear something that will make you all sick in your mouth?
我在试镜前看了一集大概三分钟，我立刻就知道我不能再看了，因为他太棒了，如果我再看下去，我就会只想模仿他正在做的事情。对。我懂。真的。我当时爆笑。你想听吗，你想听一件能让你们所有人恶心得想吐的事吗？
This is a true story. When I said yes to Teen Wolf two, I made a concerted choice, concerted choice to not see the original Teen Wolf because I didn't want to be tempted to rip anything off from Michael J. Fox and I wanted to be able to say that my version was completely, you know, just, you know, cooked up internally and still to this day, still have not seen Teen Wolf. Did that ever come up at any of the Q and A's at the director's guild? Yeah.
这是一个真实的故事。当我答应出演《少狼2》时，我做出了一个坚定的选择，坚定的选择不看原版的《少狼》，因为我不想受到诱惑去抄袭迈克尔·J·福克斯的任何东西，我想能够说我的版本完全是，你知道的，完全是内部炮制出来的，直到今天，我依然没有看《少狼》。这在导演工会的任何问答环节中提到过吗？对。
I just, you know, they kept canceling those and I got weird excuses for that. I'm not sure what was behind it, but yeah, never ended up doing any of those. But I did tell a bunch of people to junk it this story and didn't get a lot of response back. But that is true. Nobody's going to love that more than Kyle Gass is going to love that more than anybody. He's a big fan. Steve, do you have, do you have siblings by the way?
我只是，你知道的，他们一直取消那些活动，我为此得到了奇怪的借口。我不确定背后的原因是什么，但是的，最终没有做那些。但我确实告诉了一群人这个故事，却没有得到太多的回应。但那是真的。没有人会比凯尔·加斯更喜欢这个了，他是个大粉丝。史蒂夫，顺便问一下，你有兄弟姐妹吗？
I do. Three older brothers. Would you like to get rid of them? Sorry. What? What? Would you like to get rid of them? That's Will's classic follow up to the sibling question.
我有。三个哥哥。你想甩掉他们吗？抱歉。什么？什么？你想甩掉他们？那是威尔对兄弟姐妹问题的经典追问。
No, they're fantastic. But you are the youngest or the oldest? I'm the youngest. You are the youngest. Really? I'm the youngest of four boys as well. Oh really? Yes.
不，他们棒极了。但你是最小的还是最大的？我是老幺。你是老幺。真的吗？我也是四个男孩里最小的。哦，真的吗？对。
And did you, any of them interested in the business you're in? No, not at all. Did you get your ass kicked quite a bit, Steve? No, it wasn't. No. It wasn't like that. No, I was, I was like five years younger than my closest brother in age. So I was always kind of the baby.
那你们当中，有人对你从事的行业感兴趣吗？不，完全没有。史蒂夫，你屁股没少挨踢吧？没有，不是的。没有。不是那样的。不，我，我比我离得最近的兄弟小五岁左右。所以我一直算是老小。
So they always kind of protected me. I've got a couple of other Wikipedia hot tidbits here. Steve, did you ever consider, sorry, just a DJ name. Did you ever consider Baby Steve? Because it's a different, it invokes a different thing. It wouldn't please Diamond Dave as much. Was it Diamond Dave? Sapphire.
所以他们一直挺保护我的。我这还有几个维基百科的热门小八卦。史蒂夫，你有没有考虑过，抱歉，只是个DJ名字。你有没有考虑过“小史蒂夫（Baby Steve）”？因为这感觉不一样，它会唤起一种不同的感觉。它可没法像“钻石戴夫（Diamond Dave）”那样讨人喜欢。是钻石戴夫吗？蓝宝石。
Sapphire. Steve, DJ boys? Yes, please. Please. It's time to listen to Jared and Heather. I can hear them turning off already. Now, did you, is it true here that you played the fife? Oh my God.
蓝宝石。史蒂夫，DJ男孩？好的，拜托。请听杰瑞德和希瑟的节目。我都能听到他们已经关掉节目了。话说回来，这里说你吹过横笛（fife），真的吗？我的天啊。
Yeah. Can't do a lot of research. What is the fife? What's the fife? The fife is a, is essentially a flute that they would use during revolutionary war times. Certainly. And, and I was, so it was when you were doing the reenactments is when you would, I was
是啊。没做多少调查。什么是横笛？什么是横笛？横笛是一种，基本上是一种他们在独立战争时期会使用的长笛。当然。而且，我是，所以那是当你参加历史重演的时候，你是
part of a fife and drunk core. Yeah. In the act. And then you would take time off from that to just, you know, get laid all the time. So it's not a piccolo and it's not a flute. It's a fife. It's sort of, it's sort of, yes, it's a, it is an old timey piccolo. And just doubling back to the radio thing, the WDUB, that's WDUB.
一个横笛与鼓乐队的成员。是的。在表演中。然后你会从那里面抽空去，你知道的，随时随地跟人上床。所以它不是短笛，也不是长笛。它是横笛。它有点像，有点像，是的，它是一种老式的短笛。顺便回到电台的事，WDUB，那是WDUB。
Can I hear you just, just bark out the call, the callers once for us. This is Sapphire, Steve Carell and WDUB. Never WDUB? No. Huh. I think they might call it dub now. WDUB. All right.
我能听听你给我们现学现卖地喊一下呼号吗？这是蓝宝石史蒂夫·卡瑞尔和WDUB。从来没有WDUB？没有。哈。我想他们现在可能叫它dub了。WDUB。好吧。
Last on this interesting list here is that you were, and will just strap in for this pal. Okay. Sean, Sean and I can take a break here. You were a goalie on your school's hockey team, the big red for four years. Uh-huh. True? Yes.
这个有趣的名单上的最后一条是，你曾——威尔，系好安全带准备听这个吧，老兄。好吧。肖恩，肖恩和我可以在这休息一下。你曾是你学校冰球队“大红队”的守门员，长达四年。嗯哼。真的吗？是的。
I will. Go ahead. Let's talk a goalie technique. I was a goalie too, Steve. I didn't know you were a goalie. Yeah. Yeah. I played goal in hockey.
我会的。说吧。我们来聊聊守门员的技术。我也是个守门员，史蒂夫。我不知道你以前是守门员。对。对。我打过冰球守门员。
Yeah. Where would guys get the puck past both of you most easily? What was your loosest hole? Steve and I were both, were old enough that back then the guys didn't play much, they didn't play in the butterfly style as much as they do now. So it was a lot more stack in the pads, right? Remember the stack in the pads? Yeah.
对。大家最容易从你们俩中间把冰球打进去的地方是哪？你最大的漏洞是什么？史蒂夫和我年纪都够大了，那时候的家伙们不像现在这样经常采用蝶式扑救。所以当时更多的是倒地封堵，对吧？还记得倒地封堵吗？对。
And it was all angles. It was all like coming out, coming way out of the net to cut down the angle. And no face mask back then, right? No. Hey, hey now. Hey. But we did, Steve, you know, it's great. I don't know if you feel the same way when you watch those old, I imagine you're a Bruins
而且全凭角度。全都是那种冲出来，大幅冲出球门来缩小角度。而且那时候没有面具，对吧？没有。嘿，嘿。不过我们确实，史蒂夫，你知道的，这太棒了。我不知道你看那些老录像时是不是也有同感，我猜你是个棕熊
fan. Oh yeah. Yeah. And that's unfortunate. You know, there's a lot of those old videos of like Jerry Cheever's, you know, the Bruins, let's say, or Billy Smith or the Islanders. And they came out so far that the guys would make one move and then they'd have a yawning net because the goalie is like 30 yards out of the net.
球迷。哦，对。是的。而那太不幸了。你知道，有很多那种老录像，比如杰瑞·奇维尔斯的棕熊队，或者比利·史密斯或岛人队。他们冲得太远了，以至于对方只要做一个假动作，就能面对一个空门，因为守门员离球门有30码远。
Yeah. And well, I was told you have to learn how to skate backwards really well. So you, if you could skate backwards as fast as they were skating forwards and you move back with them, but still, you can come way out. Yeah. It's impossible. The game has changed so much. The equipment is different.
对。而且，有人告诉我，你必须学会非常熟练地倒着滑冰。所以你如果能像他们向前滑一样快地倒着滑，并且跟着他们往后退，但同时，你还能冲出来很多。对。这太不可思议了。比赛已经变了太多。装备也不一样了。
What was your, Will, what was your weak spot? Like where was, like, like blocker side, you know, probably blocker side, like high blocker side. That was always tough. Well, yeah. It's tough for all of them. I think it's tough for all of them. And also, and also below the block, like in that, in that, I don't know, what do they
威尔，你的弱点是什么？比如，就像，阻挡手那侧，你知道的，可能是阻挡手那侧，比如高位阻挡手那侧。那总是很难。好吧，对。对所有人来说都很难。我觉得对所有人来说都很难。而且还有，还有阻挡手下方，在那个，在那个，我不知道，他们现在叫它
call it now? They call it the, the six hole or the seven hole, just like under the arm on that side. Yeah. I think that's pretty tough. If you're, if you're pretty, you can be a lot of goalies, uh, right in there on the special. Great. Sean.
什么？他们叫它六号洞或者七号洞，就在那一侧的手臂下方。对。我觉得那挺难的。如果你，如果你很厉害，你可以在那个位置对很多守门员得分。太棒了。肖恩。
Real good. Hey guys, we just lost, they're bringing the paddles in to revive Sean. Sean, ask him if he ever auditioned for SNL coming out of Second City. Go ahead. No, I want to ask, can I just ask one quick question about the growing up? Because I think it's fascinating because, uh, in a group like that, first of all, what is Corel? What is your nationality?
非常好。嘿，伙计们，我们刚刚失去知觉了，他们正拿电击板来救醒肖恩。肖恩，问问他从第二城剧团出来后有没有为《周六夜现场》试镜过。问吧。不，我想问，我能问一个关于成长的简短问题吗？因为我觉得这很迷人，因为，在一个这样的群体里，首先，卡瑞尔是什么？你的国籍是什么？
Uh, Italian. Okay. It's, it was, it's derived from carousel. Oh, like a carousel? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Like a carousel.
呃，意大利裔。好吧。它是由旋转木马（carousel）演变而来的。哦，像旋转木马？对。对。对。就像旋转木马。
Or a carousel or something. Sean. Sean. I mean like a carousel. Okay. So wait. So you're interested in theater and, and, and, and Second City and all that. What do your brothers think of that as you're growing up?
或者某种旋转木马之类的。肖恩。肖恩。我的意思是像旋转木马。好吧。等等。所以你对戏剧、戏剧、还有第二城剧团以及所有这些感兴趣。当你长大时，你的兄弟们对此有什么看法？
Like are, are they like, that's for sissies or are they encouraging? Well, it's, it's just one of a bunch of different things that I did. So it wasn't, I don't know. I don't, they didn't give him much thought. I don't think they really cared. Like, oh, Steve's in a play. Well, that's so lovely. Well, we'll go see that.
比如他们会觉得，那是娘娘腔该干的，还是他们很鼓励？好吧，这只是我做过的一堆不同事情中的一件。所以这并不是，我不知道。我不觉得，他们没怎么在意。我觉得他们根本不在乎。比如，哦，史蒂夫在演戏剧。哦，那太可爱了。好吧，我们会去看的。
That's so lovely. I, I didn't tell anybody I was in the high school play because I was nervous to let them know about lots of things, but that I was in theater because all of my brothers are football, baseball, massive sports guys. And I remember I came home from a performance of bye bye birdie at my high school and my brother goes, um, Hey, I know you're in the play. I'm like, I freaked out. I was like, you do?
那太可爱了。我，我没有告诉任何人我参加了高中戏剧社，因为我对于让他们知道很多事情感到紧张，特别是我是戏剧社的，因为我的所有兄弟都是踢足球、打棒球的超级体育迷。我记得我从高中演出的《再见，伯蒂》回来后，我哥说：“呃，嘿，我知道你参加了戏剧演出。”我当时吓坏了。我说：“你才知道？”
He goes, yeah, I mean, I'm in football. We were makeup too. We put the black stuff under our eyes. It's cool. Everybody wears makeup. So he was trying to give you a green light saying it's okay. Let us know. Sean.
他说：“对啊，我是说，我也是踢足球的。我们也化妆啊。我们在眼睛底下涂黑色的东西。这很酷。每个人都化妆。”所以他是在试图给你开绿灯，说这没关系。让我们知道。肖恩。
Yeah. Now in your school, Sean, was there like a huge delineation between like athletics and, and art and theater and that sort of thing? There was. I mean, we had, we had a couple of people crossover from when I say couple, I really mean like maybe one or two from the sports into, into the theater, but it was mainly, a lot of it was, was it's probably more integrated now. Yeah.
对。那么在你的学校里，肖恩，体育和艺术、戏剧以及诸如此类的东西之间，是否有非常明显的分界线？有的。我的意思是，我们有，我们有几个人跨界，当我说是几个人时，我真的意思大概是一两个从体育界跨界到戏剧界，但主要还是，很多都是，现在可能更融合了吧。对。
Yeah. It was, it was, it was a small school. So everybody kind of dabbled in everything. So there wasn't, there, there wasn't a built in stigma to any of it. And I actually directed, uh, like a, a melodrama and cast everybody from the hockey team and it was, and guys who had never been on stage before. And it was one of the funniest things. That's great.
对。那是个小学校。所以每个人都多多少少涉猎各种事情。因此这里面并没有什么内建的偏见。我甚至还导演过，呃，类似于情节剧，把冰球队的所有人都拉来演了，还有那些从未上过舞台的家伙。那绝对是最搞笑的事情之一。太棒了。
That's how it should be. Yeah. It was really, really fun. What do folks think when you were like showing an interest, what kind of stuff, what, what kind of line of work were your, your parents and like, um, my mom was a psych nurse. Okay. Uh, she worked the night shift, uh, at a hospital. Wow.
事情本该如此。对。真的非常有趣。当你们表现出兴趣时，大家是怎么想的？你们的父母是做什么工作的，比如，呃，我妈妈是一名精神科护士。好吧。呃，她在医院上夜班。哇。
I bet you she's got great stories. Oh my gosh. She, well, she did it for like 40 years. Um, and it's, it was a lot. You know, I, I, I have so much respect for what she did and sure really, uh, I, I, I, uh, worked very hard and she was good at her job. My, um, my dad was, uh, an engineer. Did you talk to her at all about the, the patient at all?
我敢打赌她有很多精彩的故事。哦，天哪。她，嗯，她干了大约40年。呃，而且那很不简单。你知道，我，我，我对她所做的事充满敬意，而且她真的，呃，我，我，呃，工作非常努力，而且她很擅长她的工作。我，呃，我爸爸是一名工程师。你有没有跟她聊过关于病人的事？
Is she still with us? She's not. No, she passed away about five years ago. Um, but I think a lot of, a lot of what I learned from her, I've implemented in that. Yeah. And to the patient, which is your new show on FX that is too great. Oh wow. I play a therapist in it.
她还健在吗？她不在了。没有，她大约五年前去世了。嗯，但我想我从她那里学到的很多东西，我都运用到了那里面。是的。还有《The Patient》，这是你在FX上的新剧，太棒了。哦，哇。我在里面扮演一个治疗师。
I think I gleaned a lot of stuff from her when I was growing up. Is that one of the reasons you took the role is because it was so close to what you would close, close to what your mom has taught you? Um, in part, I just find that world fascinating and mostly though, it was the creators, uh, the guys who did the Americans and I, I'm a huge fan of that show. Did you, you were going to say that she never talked? She never talked about anyone because, you know, we lived in the, the small towns, um, right?
我觉得我在成长过程中从她身上学到了很多东西。这也是你接演这个角色的原因之一吗？因为它非常接近你所关闭的……非常接近你妈妈教导你的？嗯，部分原因吧，我只是觉得那个世界很迷人，但主要还是因为创作者，呃，制作《美国谍梦》的那帮人，我非常喜欢那部剧。你刚才想说她从来不说话吗？她从不谈论任何人，因为，你知道，我们住在小镇上，对吧？
She, she worked in Concord. We lived in the next town over. So she never talked about anyone that she was treating or talking to. Oh my God. She told me so many things. But, but, but Steve, is that at the risk of maybe seeing them at the stop and shop or exactly? I mean, professional courtesy, obviously, and, um, but in terms of the, of what she did,
她，她在康科德工作。我们住在隔壁镇。所以她从来不谈论她治疗或交谈过的任何人。哦，天哪。她告诉我很多事情。但是，但是，但是史蒂夫，这会不会有在Stop & Shop超市遇到他们或者类似情况的风险？我的意思是，职业礼貌显然是有的，而且，嗯，但就她的所作所为而言，
you know, we talked a lot about that and, and the types of people that she was treating and, and caring for and to have empathy for no matter how sick or broken somebody might be. Yeah. Um, reminds me of my, my personal favorite performance, uh, you've done thus far, uh, John Dupont, uh, in Foxcatcher, uh, a fellow who clearly didn't have his feet completely underneath them. Um, but you played him with so much like, I don't know, like, like any good villain,
你知道的，我们对此进行了很多讨论，关于她所治疗和照顾的人的类型，无论一个人多么生病或破碎，都要对他产生同理心。是的。嗯，这让我想起了我个人最喜欢的你迄今为止的表演，呃，约翰·杜邦，在《狐狸猎手》中，一个明显脚跟没有完全站稳的人。嗯，但你演出了很多，我不知道，就像任何一个优秀的恶棍一样，
uh, you, you should feel some empathy in a sort of an unsettling way for them. And you're just able to do that. Were you as furious? I know your answer. You won't answer this. Were you as furious when you didn't win the Oscar for that? I thought, my God, it's over. It's done.
呃，你，你对他们应该会有一种不安的同情。而你偏偏能做到这一点。你当时一样愤怒吗？我知道你的答案。你不会回答这个。当你在那个奖项上没有赢得奥斯卡时，你也是一样愤怒吗？我想，天哪，一切都结束了。都成了过去式。
As soon as I said, everyone's playing for a second now. You, by the way, you, you and Channing should have both. Seriously. Oh, Channing, Channing and Mark were both fantastic. No one touched you in that film, Steve, you leave them alone. You took that and, and this was before, I mean, what Bennett Miller, what, did you have an incredible meeting with him? I mean, he called, he called me, he out of the blue, he called me like, I, I had never
我话音刚落，现在大家都在争夺第二名。顺便说一句，你、你和查宁本来都应该。说真的。哦，查宁、查宁和马克都太棒了。史蒂夫，在那部电影里没人能比得过你，别管他们了。你接下了那个角色，而且是在那之前，我是说，贝内特·米勒，你和他有过一次极其精彩的会面吗？我的意思是，他打了电话，他突然打电话给我，就像我，我从来没有过
met the man. I was a fan of his work, but my agent called and said, you know, he wanted to talk to you about it. He wants to talk to you about a project. So it's, and it's one of those moments you think, what's, what's, what is this about? What's going on? Like, how would I even possibly be on this guy's radar? And he laid out what he was looking for and, and I just joined it instantly, you know,
见到了这个人。我很欣赏他的作品，但我的经纪人打电话说，他想跟你谈谈。他想跟你谈一个项目。所以，这真的是那种你会想，这、这、这到底是怎么回事？发生了什么？就像，我怎么可能会进入这个人的视线呢？然后他详细说明了他在寻找什么，我立刻就加入了，你知道的
the chance to do something like that. Was that kind of vision in you and faith in you, uh, uh, terrifying or did it, or did it give you the kind of encouragement that you wanted and needed in order to play that part, you know, that someone saw it in you before you even thought about it, maybe. I don't know how you guys feel about like when you, you take on parts or get jobs. I, if, if you're a little, and it's, I think it sounds like a cliche at this point, but if you're a little uneasy about it, if you're a little scared, I think that's good. Yeah.
有机会去做那样的事情。这种远见和对你的信任，呃，呃，是让人感到害怕，还是说，它给了你想要的那种鼓励和支持，让你能够去饰演那个角色，你知道的，就是在你甚至自己都没考虑到之前，就有人在你身上看到了这种潜力，也许吧。我不知道你们在接角色或者找工作的时候是怎么想的。我，如果，如果你有点——我想现在听起来像是个老生常谈的话题了——但如果你对此有点不安，如果你有点害怕，我觉得那是件好事。是的。
You work harder. I think so. I think it's like that unknown that, that quality of, because if you go in thinking, oh, I've, I know how to do this from day one, but like, why do it if you really think you've got it always figured out? Well, well, I was going to say, I was going to say to that kind of goes back to what we're saying before about being shy or not or performing or not the truth be told. And I know I can act like a pompous ass a lot of time and seemingly not shy or whatever.
你会更努力。我也这么认为。我觉得就像那种未知的东西，那种品质，因为如果你带着“哦，我第一天就知道怎么做”的想法去，但是，如果你真的觉得自己什么都想通了，那为什么还要做呢？嗯，嗯，我要说的是，我要说的是，这有点回到我们之前说的关于害羞还是不害羞，或者表演还是不表演的实话实说。我知道我很多时候表现得像个自大狂，而且看起来一点也不害羞之类的。
I have a lot of moments where I think like jump or don't, and especially when it comes to like doing things and saying things and stepping out, you know, with like improv like stepping out. And my instinct that always just tells me to just do it and to just go for and be uncomfortable and who knows what's going to happen. And I feel nervous and just to embrace that nervousness. So I am nervous quite often and I just try to use it and or embrace it. Yeah.
我有很多时刻会觉得是该跳还是不该跳，尤其是当要做某些事、说某些话以及迈出步子的时候，你知道的，就像即兴表演那样迈出步子。我的直觉总是告诉我，去做就是了，去放手一搏，去经历不适，谁知道会发生什么呢。我感到紧张，那就去拥抱这种紧张感。所以我经常会感到紧张，我只是试着去利用它，或者拥抱它。是的。
Cause I also find the courage lives on the other side of trying, you know, it's like, you don't, don't expect courage before you actually go for it. Yeah, I totally agree. I mean, I think that's, and that's what's exciting about it. And that's when you find new things and if you don't know, you can do it. I think that's good. Yeah. Or if you fear that you can't even that's give it a shot.
因为我也发现勇气往往在尝试的另一边，你知道的，就好像你不要期望在真正去争取之前就能拥有勇气。是的，我完全同意。我的意思是，我认为这就是它的精彩之处，这也是你发现新事物的时候，如果你不知道你能做到，我认为那很好。是的。或者如果你害怕你做不到，哪怕那样也去试一试。
Yeah. We'll be right back. SmartList is brought to you in part by Audible. With our schedules, it's not always possible to sit down with a book and read uninterrupted, but that's where Audible comes in. Audible makes it possible to listen to audio books across every genre from best sellers and new releases to celebrity memoirs, mysteries, thrillers, motivation, wellness, business, all kinds of stuff.
是的。我们马上回来。《SmartList》部分内容由 Audible 赞助播出。按我们的日程安排，要坐下来安安静静读完一本书并不总是那么容易，但这就是 Audible 派上用场的地方。Audible 让你可以聆听涵盖各个流派的有声书，从畅销书、新书发售到名人回忆录、悬疑小说、惊悚小说、励志、健康、商业，各种内容应有尽有。
As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from their entire catalog, including the latest best sellers and new releases. All Audible members get access to a growing selection of audio books, Audible originals and podcasts that are included with membership. You can listen to all you want and more get added every month. It's perfect for me because anyone who's been listening knows that I have some sort of weird allergy to reading. I'm not proud of it, but it's there and Audible is a great fix for me because I love listening
作为Audible会员，您每个月可以从其整个目录中选择并拥有⼀本书，包括最新的畅销书和新发布的作品。所有Audible会员都可以访问不断增加的有声读物、Audible原创作品和播客，这些都包含在会员资格中。您可以尽情收听，并且每个月都会添加更多内容。这对我来说简直完美，因为听过节目的都知道我对阅读有一种奇怪的过敏反应。我对此并不骄傲，但事实确实如此，而Audible对我的问题是一个极好的解决方法，因为我喜欢听
to stuff. So let Audible help you discover new ways to laugh, be inspired, be entertained. New members can try it for free for 30 days. Try Audible.com slash smartlist or text Audible to 500-500, that's Audible.com slash smartlist or text smartlist to 500-500 to try Audible for free for 30 days, Audible.com slash smartlist. All right, back to the show. Let me ask you this too because I can say it, I know you won't. You've completely conquered comedy.
填满生活。所以让 Audible 帮你发现欢笑、灵感和娱乐的新方式。新会员可以免费试用 30 天。访问 Audible.com slash smartlist 或发送短信 Audible 到 500-500，即 Audible.com slash smartlist 或发送短信 smartlist 到 500-500 即可免费试用 Audible 30 天，Audible.com slash smartlist。好了，回到节目中。我也想问你这个，因为我可以直说，我知道你不会。你已经在喜剧界取得了彻底的成功。
Everybody knows it. You're brilliant at it. So are you always actively seeking things that aren't funny, things that challenge you a little more because you know that you've kind of conquered that area already? Not really. It's weird to even talk about what I choose to do because I still feel like how am I employed? Me too. I'm sure.
每个人都知道。你在这方面太棒了。那你是不是总是在主动寻找不好笑的东西、那些更能挑战你的东西，因为你知道你已经在某种程度上征服了那个领域？其实没有。甚至谈论我选择做什么都很奇怪，因为我仍然觉得我怎么还能找到工作？我也是。我敢肯定。
You can tell with you guys too. It's like being so thankful for even getting to work is really cool. But no, I've never kind of picked and choose. I don't have a good sort of broad view of where my career is or should be going. It's just kind of… Gig to gig. Kind of, yeah. Like trusting your instincts, if it's something like those guys, I really wanted to work with
你们也是这样。那种对能有工作心存感激的感觉真的很酷。不过说实话，我从来没有挑挑拣拣过。我对自己的职业生涯在哪里或者应该走向何方，并没有一个宏观的规划。基本上就是……一份工作接一份工作。差不多吧。就像是相信自己的直觉，如果是像那些人那样的工作，我真的很想参与。
the guys who did The Americans. Nancy and I fell in love with the show, fell in love with Ozark as well, if I ever get a chance to work with any of that team, my God, like that's what drew me to it. And I thought it may not be good this time, but just to get a chance to work with people like that. Yeah. I too, I'm such a big fan of so many people in this business. If any one of them ever called me, it wouldn't matter how big or small the role is, what
创作《美国谍梦》的那群人。南希和我非常喜欢这部剧，也很喜欢《黑钱胜地》，如果我能有机会和他们团队的任何人合作，天哪，那就是吸引我的地方。我想这次可能不会好，但只要有机会和这样的人合作。是的。我也是，我是这个行业里很多人的超级粉丝。如果他们中的任何一个人打电话给我，无论角色是大是小，都不重要
the money is, where it shoots, blah, blah. It's just that's the big influencer on me on what I choose to do to the extent I have a choice. If you're like me, you basically take everything you're given. There's not a lot of jobs that overlap where it's like, ah, this one's in conflict with that one I got to pick. It's just it's either yes or no, I'll just stay unemployed for a while. So going on, going further into your incredible, we're going to pull that one up right there.
钱在哪里，它拍哪里，等等之类。这对我选择做什么有着巨大影响，在我有选择的范围内。如果你像我一样，你基本上是照单全收。没有多少工作会有重叠，让你觉得，啊，这个和那个有冲突，我必须得选一个。这其实很简单，要么是或不是，大不了我失业一段时间。所以接下来，更深入地探讨你那不可思议的……我们马上就把那个调出来。
Going into your canon of incredible roles, let's go to the other side into comedy. Let's go to 40 year old virgin where I, if I might be right or wrong, that you co-wrote, co-created that, that that was an idea with you. If that is correct, when did that first idea of the 40 year old virgin come to you aside from perhaps the obvious answer? Oh, no, it's not me. I mean, I don't know. It's not me.
说到你那些令人难以置信的经典角色，让我们转向另一个领域——喜剧。让我们来看看《四十岁的老处男》，如果我没记错的话，那是你参与编剧和创作的，这个创意最早是你想出来的吗？如果确实如此，除了那个显而易见的答案之外，最初关于《四十岁的老处男》这个点子是什么时候产生的？哦，不，不是我。我的意思是，我不知道。不是我。
It's okay. No. It's a little me. It's a little. It's like the 30 year old virgin. It's, you know, it was a sketch that we tried. I kept trying. You know, it was a second city sketch.
没关系。不，这有点像我。这有点像。就像《四十岁的老处男》。你知道的，这是我们尝试过的一个小品。我一直在尝试。你知道的，这是第二城的滑稽短剧。
I kept trying to get it in a show and it was like, you guys, I have this idea and it was essentially in, in the 40 year old virgin, the seed of the idea was the poker sequence when this guy gets invited out by his, his working, you know, not buddies at that point, but coworkers and they're all regaling each other with these tales of sexual conquest and he doesn't have any context, doesn't, doesn't, hasn't done it, doesn't know how to talk about it and he starts to improvise the most ridiculous things about like what it feels like to touch a woman's breast and, you know, and he's just way, way wrong and they call him out on.
我一直试图把它搬上节目，就像是，各位，我有这样一个想法，基本上就是，在《四十岁的老处男》里，这个想法的萌芽就是那个扑克牌的场景，当时这家伙被他当时还不是死党、只是同事的家伙们邀请出去，他们都在向彼此讲述那些性征服的故事，而他完全没有概念，没有经历过，不知道该怎么谈论，于是他开始即兴胡编一些极其荒谬的事情，比如摸女人的胸部是什么感觉，你知道的，而且他错得离谱，被他们当场拆穿了。
So that after I did Anchorman, Judd Aptow said, if you ever have any ideas, you know, I'd love to meet with you and you can pitch anything you want to me. So I went in and I pitched a completely separate idea for about an hour and he was like, oh, yeah, it's pretty good. Yeah, let's keep talking about it. So it kind of went nowhere. And as I was walking out the door, I said, oh, and there's this other thing, a 40 year old virgin.
所以在我拍完《王牌播音员》之后，贾德·阿帕图说，如果你有什么想法，你知道的，我很乐意和你见面，你可以向我推销你想推销的任何东西。所以我去了，推销了一个完全不同的想法，大约一个小时，他当时就说，哦，是的，挺不错的。好吧，我们继续讨论吧。所以它基本上没个下文。当我正要出门时，我说，哦，还有另一件事，叫做《四十岁的老处男》。
I gave him like a 20 second pitch and he looked at me and said, that I can sell this weekend. Like he was on it instantly. Yeah. And that's how that came together. That's a great idea. That's great. Now, was, was Anchorman on the page or, or did you come up with a lot of that on, on the day as far as the style of that character goes?
我向他进行了大约20秒的陈述，他看着我说，这个周末我就能把它卖掉。就像他瞬间就被吸引了。是的，事情就是这样促成的。这真是个好主意。太棒了。那么，当时《王牌播音员》剧本上就已经写好了，还是说那个角色的风格很大程度上是你们在拍摄当天即兴发挥的？
I think a lot of it was on the page. I, you know, I, I never want to take credit for something like the office. The writing of that show was so fantastic. And there was some improv that went on, but, you know, you just, I, you have to give credit like Adam McKay is such a funny dude and, and half the, half the improvisation, it was him like, you know, behind the camera, just yelling stuff out that we should say. And then we say it and we get credit for saying it. But the credit you do deserve to take is you have a very keen sense of what, what your
我认为很多功劳其实都在剧本上。我，你知道，我，我绝不想把功劳全揽在自己身上，比如像《办公室》这部剧。这部剧的编剧太棒了。虽然里面有一些即兴发挥，但是，你知道，你必须把功劳归于像亚当·麦凯这样非常搞笑的家伙，而且一半，一半的即兴创作其实是他在镜头后面，大喊一些我们该说的话。然后我们照着说，结果功劳却记在我们头上。不过你确实应该得到的功劳是，你有着敏锐的直觉，能够敏锐地察觉到你的
funny is and what your funny isn't in that you have, you have such an ease into vulnerability and, and, and, and, and cringe inducing embarrassment. Like there is, you have, you have, you're not afraid to pull your pants down metaphorically. And there, you put that in a lot of your characters, which is just, it's so courageous and so hilarious. Even when you're playing a guy who's arrogant, it's just so way for thin and it's, it just, it just kills me. And I don't know if you can write that as my point.
有趣的是你的有趣与否在于你能够如此自然地展礰出脆弱感以及那种伐善可阻的尴尴。就像是你不怕数扄性地脱掉苦子。而你将这一点用到你的许多角色上，这真的是太有勇气又太搞笑了。就算你演的是个自大的家余，那层瓮薄的膜也是不塕可击，真的是笑死我了。我不知道你是否能把这写进去作为我的观点。
You know, you, it's like, it's in the eyes. There's a vulnerability, a generosity of spirit that you have with your character. My internet may be going out, but it was kind of choppy was just pull your pants down and it's way for thin. How do you respond to that? Steve, did you have any other like sketch ideas from second city that you wished would have become? And you want to pin them to now and we'll cut them out.
你知道吗，你，就像是，它就在眼睛里。你的角色有一种脆弱感，有一种慷慨的精神。我的网络可能要断了，但刚才有点卡顿，就是把裤子脱下来，这太单薄了。你对此有什么回应？史蒂夫，你还有其他来自第二城市剧团的素描点子吗，你希望它们能变成现实？你想把它们定格到现在，然后我们把它剪掉。
If they're really good, we'll cut them out and we'll sell them back to the answer on my, you know, it's, it's, and I'm sure you guys look back at stuff that you did that you think, boy, that at the time you're, you're thinking, this is, this is really working. And you reflect on it 20 years later and you think that's just the worst. I did a song, I did a song parody of Bobby McFerrin's Don't Worry, Be Happy. And I wrote a song parody for one of our shows that was Don't Worry, Be Affluent as sung by Dan Quayle.
如果它们真的很棒，我们会把它们剪辑下来，然后把它们卖回给我的答案，你知道的，这，这，而且我确信你们回首自己做过的事情时会想，天哪，当时你们会想，这，这真的很有用。二十年后你再反思它，你会觉得那简直糟透了。我做过一首歌，我恶搞了鲍比·麦克费林的《别担心，要快乐》。我为我们的一个节目写了一首恶搞歌曲，叫做《别担心，要富裕》，由丹·奎尔演唱。
And it was the worst. It was so bad. And so obvious and at the time I thought audience, I mean, got in a show, audience is loving it. You're welcome. And it, and there was no wit to it. It was, it vaguely rhymed, it was terrible. So no, there was just, there, there's a lot of stuff that deserve to be left on the chopping
而且那是糟糕透顶。真的太差了。而且太明显了，当时我还想，观众嘛，我是说，上了节目，观众都很喜欢。不用谢。而且，而且一点机智都没有。就是，勉强押了韵，简直糟透了。所以不，就是有，有很多东西确实该被抛弃不用。
block, I think. Okay. So they did, those are the ones that deserve to be left on the chopping bug. What was, what's the thing, the idea, the thing that never got made or that you had in development at the studio? Did you ever have an idea or a movie that you're like, God damn it, that I'm sure none of your stuff got put in to turn around. But I had like three or four things that I have never been made to this day.
I still think that would be the funniest. One thing that Mike Schur and I sold years ago, we sold to DreamWorks and that's still there. It's brilliant, obviously Mike Schur is a brilliant writer and you know him well, but, but do you have any of those things of like, I wish this thing? Well, Tina Fey wrote something that I wish we had gotten to do. It was called mail order groom. And it's about a woman who works at a video store at the, this is how old the idea was.
我仍然觉得那会是最搞笑的。迈克·舒尔和我多年前卖过一个创意，我们把它卖给了梦工厂，现在还在那儿。它当然很棒，迈克·舒尔显然是个才华横溢的编剧，你也很了解他，但是，你有没有过那种想法，比如：我真希望这个项目能实现？蒂娜·菲写过一个剧本，我真希望我们当时能把它拍出来。它叫《邮购新郎》。讲的是一个在录像带租赁店工作的女性的故事——从这就能看出这个创意有多老了。
Who it basically flies to Russia to marry this guy, like a mail order groom. She sees this, I don't even remember how it all starts. And I'm the mail order groom. And so she brings me back to the United States essentially to get one of her coworkers jealous. Did he have the grew accent? It's all the grew accent. I mean, that's, yeah, I'm sure if we'd done it, it would have been grew. And so, and obviously we end up kind of warming up to each other and eventually falling in
基本上，她飞到俄罗斯去和这个家伙结婚，就像一个邮购新郎。她看到了这个，我甚至不记得这一切是怎么开始的。而我就是那个邮购新郎。于是她把我带回美国，基本上是为了让她的一个同事嫉妒。他有格鲁那种口音吗？全都是格鲁口音。我的意思是，那是，是的，我敢肯定如果我们做了，那就会是格鲁的口音。所以，很明显，我们最后还是对彼此有了好感，并最终坠入
love and there's a, actually, Will, you were, you were who we were talking about to play the immigration agent. No kidding. He sounds interesting. Like if, if it had, if it had gone, you were like, for some of our lists to play, you know, the guy who's like, Well, let me check. Yeah.
爱，而且其实，威尔，你就是我们当时在讨论扮演移民官的人。真的吗？听起来很有趣。如果，如果真的那样发展的话，在我们的候选名单里，你曾是那种扮演……你知道的，就是那种会说“嗯，让我查查”的人。是的。
I'm available. I mean, I'm just saying, let's fire this up. Steve, let's get this going. Steve, I don't need a commitment out of you now. All I'm saying is if I get this off the ground with Tina and you, and obviously we'll update. It's not going to be a video store. It'll be at a Tik Tok conference, but is where she works, but, but I'm just saying don't rule it out.
我随时奉陪。我的意思是，我只是说，让我们开始干吧。史蒂夫，让我们行动起来吧。史蒂夫，我现在不需要你做任何承诺。我只想说，如果我和蒂娜以及你把这个项目做起来，显然我们会进行更新。这不会是一个录像带商店。它将在一个TikTok会议上举行，就在她工作的地方，但是，我只是说不要排除这种可能性。
Steve, I want to ask you a question. When you travel back and forth, she said six months on six months off on each coast. When you go back to LA after being on the East coast in Boston, which is so different, is there a culture shock and what are the things you noticed that you didn't notice before having now made the move and having time away? Anything? Um, I think the main thing is that when somebody sees me in a supermarket here, they, they just, they give me shit.
史蒂夫，我想问你一个问题。当你两头跑的时候，正如她所说，东西海岸各住半年。当你从波士顿这个极具特色的东海岸回到洛杉矶时，会有文化冲击吗？在你已经搬家并离开了一段时间之后，有哪些是你以前没注意到现在却注意到的事情？有什么吗？嗯，我想最主要的一点是，当有人在这里的超市看到我时，他们，他们只是，他们会调侃我。
They're like, Hey, Steve, don't get cocky. Yeah. And they're very sweet about it. Okay. That new show. All right. Don't get cocky. Right.
他们就像是在说，嘿，史蒂夫，别得意忘形。是的。而且他们对此非常温和。好的。那个新节目。好吧。别得意忘形。对吧。
Yeah. Right. Whereas in LA, you'll find a script in your shopping cart. It's a little different. Yeah. Um, but yeah, the people, I mean, the people, I, I think they, well, generally know that I'm from the area. Sure.
是的。对的。而在洛杉矶，你的购物车里都能翻出个剧本。情况有点不一样。是的。嗯，但是，人们，我是说，人们，我，我觉得他们，嗯，通常知道我是本地人。当然。
Yeah. I just didn't know if you got back to LA. If you were like, Oh, I forgot about this. I forgot about the way this is or that is, or this person is, or that person is because in Boston, I don't get that. It's just, it's very sleepy back here. That's the main difference. I find it Boston.
是的。我只是不知道你是否回到了洛杉矶。如果你当时在想，哦，我把这事给忘了。我忘了这里或那里是怎样的，这个人或那个人是怎样的，因为在波士顿，我没有那种感觉。这里非常安静，这就是最大的区别。我觉得波士顿是这样的。
I have, I have obviously Amy's from Boston. I've spent a lot of time out there. I have my own lifelong love affair with the people of Massachusetts. And I always liked the, uh, oh, look at you must be nice. Huh? The, the must, the must be nice, which is so good. You're in California now. Huh?
我有，埃米显然是波士顿人。我在那儿待了很长时间。我对马萨诸塞州的人民有着一见钟情般的长久热爱。我一直很喜欢那个，呃，哦，看看你，一定很好吧？哈？那个，那个，一定很好，真是太棒了。你现在在加利福尼亚，对吧？哈？
Must be nice. Steve, Steve, you're doing all right. Huh? Must be nice. Must be nice. All right. I gotta go. Yeah.
那可真不错。史蒂夫，史蒂夫，你现在过得挺好，对吧？真不错。真不错。行了。我得走了。对。
That's, you know what I mean? Yeah. No, there's a, there's a built-in familiarity and, and they don't, and, and generally it's there's, there's not a lot of lingering. It's like a glancing blow like, Hey, you know, you, I know you. See you later. Right. And that's it.
就是，你知道我的意思吗？对。不，有一种，有一种与生俱来的熟悉感，而且他们不会，而且一般来说，不会，不会有很多的纠缠。就像是一个擦边球，嘿，你知道，你，我认识你。回头见。对吧？就是这样。
Yeah. Right. Hidden rise. There's a sweetest. Sean, do you remember you and I auditioned for a movie at the same time? Uh-oh. That's right. Down with love.
是的。没错。暗中崛起。有一个最甜蜜的。肖恩，你还记得你和我同时去试镜一部电影吗？噢哦。没错。《爱情无计》 。
I mean, our paths really haven't crossed much, but I, I remember how in awe I was of you during that time. That's very sweet. And I, and I of you. And now he's much more just in awe of you, you know what I mean? That's very kind. Steve, thank you. I feel the same way about you.
我的意思是，我们的交集其实并不多，但我，我记得当时我是多么地崇拜你。真是太甜了。而且我，我也很崇拜你。而现在他更只是崇拜你了，你知道我的意思吗？这太客气了。史蒂夫，谢谢你。我对你也有同感。
Do you remember that? I do remember that. I do remember seeing you. I felt the same way. I was like, Oh my God. You were so nice. Steve, what do you do? What do you do other than, could be, we like to ask people, what do you do other than being
你还记得那个吗？我确实记得。我确实记得见过你。我也有同感。当时我想，我的天哪。你人真好。史蒂夫，你是做什么工作的？除了……我们喜欢问别人，除了……你还做什么工作
just super talented and working on tons of stuff? Is there, do you, do you still play hockey? Do you have any hobbies? Do you play golf? Do you play tennis? Do you play Scrabble? What do you want the audience not to know about you? Um, I still play a little bit of hockey when I can.
简直是才华横溢而且手头有无数的事情？有没有，你，你还打曲棍球吗？你有什么爱好吗？你打高尔夫球吗？你打网球吗？你玩拼字游戏吗？你希望观众对你有什么不知道的？嗯，只要有机会，我还是会打一点曲棍球。
Uh, I'm, I'm in a league, but you're not in, you're not between the pipes anymore. No, no, no, no, no, I gave that no, God, no, that would be, but you play, you play like Shinny or do you guys wear full equipment? Full equipment. Yeah. We have uniforms and the whole thing. Well, why don't you play in that? Well, pick up.
呃，我，我在一个联赛里，但你不在了，你不在门前防守了。不，不，不，不，我再也不了，天哪，不，那会，但你们打，你们打的是友谊赛还是穿全套装备？全套装备。对。我们有队服和全套东西。那，你为什么不打那个？呃，那是随便凑人的野球赛。
Yeah. Maybe can you, uh, do you guys ever need extras to come, think about coming into skate again? Really? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Anytime. I play D. I'd love to come play.
是啊。也许你可以，呃，你们以后还需要临时演员再来滑冰吗？真的吗？对。对。对。随时可以。我打防守，我很乐意来打球。
Can I watch? For sure. It's really serious. Okay. How long does it take to put all that equipment on? How long? Four hours. And then eight hours to wash the smell off.
我可以看吗？当然可以。这真的很严肃。好的。穿戴好所有这些装备需要多长时间？多长时间？四个小时。然后还要花八个小时把气味洗掉。
Right. My dad's not around anymore to time my skates. So it takes longer. Did your dad do that? Did your dad help you with equipment? Dude. I'm so old that when I grew up in Toronto, that my first team that I played on, Mordale, the rink was at the end of the street and it was an outdoor rink in Toronto.
对。我爸爸已经不在了，不能帮我计时了。所以花的时间更长。你爸爸做过那些事吗？你爸爸帮你弄装备吗？老兄。我太老了，我在多伦多长大的时候，我加入的第一支球队叫莫代尔，冰场就在街尽头，那是多伦多一个露天冰场。
And, and I remember vividly getting such, my, my fingers were so cold and trying to do it. My skates. And I, and I got a little bit of frostbite at my skates and I came in, I was probably like seven, six or seven, one of my first organized and I came in there to put my feet in a, they, they had like a tin that cookies come in and they put cold water in because you don't put your feet right into hot water if you're going to have potential hypothermia because it's too shocking.
而且，我清楚地记得当时手指冻得冰凉，试图去系冰鞋鞋带。我的冰鞋……我当时脚趾有点冻伤，我走进屋里时大概七岁，六七岁左右，那是我第一次参加有组织的活动之一。我进去把脚泡在一个……他们拿了一个装曲奇的铁盒，里面装了冷水，因为如果有轻度低体温症的风险，你不能马上把脚泡进热水里，因为刺激太大了。
And they put my feet into a, my grandmother was there with me, I remember, and put them into this thing and, and it felt like burning. And I remember, yes. So I remember all those things of doing up my skates, do you remember the skate tight nerves that had the hook on it? A little hook. Yeah. Yeah.
然后他们把我的脚塞进一个，我祖母当时和我在一起，我记得，把它们放进这个东西里，然后，感觉像在烧灼。我记得，是的。所以我记得所有这些系冰鞋带的事情，你还记得那个带钩子的冰鞋紧线器吗？一个小钩子。是的。是的。
And I remember that. And yeah, my parents used to take me to God's Saturday mornings. We'd have practice indoor games and I had a paper route and I remember having my mom station wagon with the back down and she would drive slowly and I'd run with the insert papers to the different houses and then to the, the game at like six a.m. And I got to, to my, to both my folks who are listening, definitely thank you so much. I don't know if I've ever proudly thank you for all those early mornings. So thank you.
我还记得那件事。是的，我父母以前常在周六早上带我去“上帝之家”。我们在那里进行室内游戏练习，我当时还要送报纸。我记得我妈开着旅行车，后排放倒，她开得很慢，我则跑着把夹缝广告报纸送到不同的房子，然后去参加早上六点左右的比赛。对于正在收听节目录音的我的父母，我非常感谢你们。我不知道我是否曾为此骄傲地向你们表达过谢意，感谢你们陪伴我度过的那些清晨。谢谢你们。
Oh, I know. Just, yeah. They sit for hours and just watch. For hours, right? Yeah. And I used to just throw all the pamphlets in the forest, say I delivered them. Sean, we're going to have a long talk after this. Sean, this has not been a great moment for you.
哦，我知道。就是，对。他们一坐就是几个小时，光是看着。几个小时，对吧？对。而我以前总是把所有的宣传册扔进森林里，还说我已经派送完了。肖恩，节目结束后我们要好好谈谈。肖恩，对你来说这可不是什么高光时刻。
It's not been great for you. Okay. The Steve Carell episode for you has been a real fucking low. Stick around after this interview. Okay. Steve, I'm sorry we're ending on a low note, but you are incredible. You have been very generous with your time. You are a dream.
这对你来说可不太妙。好吧。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔这一集对你来说真是一个该死的低谷。在这段采访结束后留下来。好吧，史蒂夫，很抱歉我们以低谷结束，但你太棒了。你对时间的付出非常慷慨。你真是一个梦想。
Please keep giving all your giving cause we'll keep taking and watching. And thank you for the hour today. And my best to you, your radio career, your wife, your kids, all of it. And we're going to come up. I, Steve, I'm going to watch. I can't wait to watch your show. And you've always been, we've only met a handful of times over the years, but you're, you're a true gentleman.
请继续支持我们，因为我们会一直接受并关注。谢谢你今天的陪伴。祝你、你的广播事业、你的妻子、你的孩子们一切都好。我们会过去的。史蒂夫，我会看的。我等不及要看你的节目了。这些年来我们其实只见过几次面，但你一直都是个真正的绅士。
And you start skating together now. Yeah. And let's skate. I'm going to get your email from these guys. For sure. Very, very low pressure hockey. You'll enjoy it. It's great.
你们现在开始一起滑冰了。是的。咱们滑冰吧。我会从这些人那里拿到你的电子邮箱。一定的。非常非常轻松的曲棍球。你会喜欢的。太棒了。
Great. Love to. Thank you, Steve Carell. Thanks guys. I love you. Thank you, Steve Carell. Look at that. Look at that.
太好了。我很乐意。谢谢你，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。谢谢大家。我爱你们。谢谢你，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。看看那个。看看那个。
Steve Carell's on the show. You guys are great. Thank you. Unbelievable. I wish we had applause. Let's just give Steve a clap. We'll pipe it in. We'll pipe them off.
史蒂夫·卡瑞尔要来节目。你们太棒了。谢谢。简直难以置信。希望我们有掌声。让我们为史蒂夫鼓个掌吧。我们会把掌声录进去。我们会把它们放出来。
All right. Thank you, Steve. Thanks guys. Bye, Steve. Thank you. Sean. Now, Sean. Sean, we have to talk to you.
好的。谢谢你，史蒂夫。谢谢大家。再见，史蒂夫。谢谢。肖恩。现在，肖恩。肖恩，我们得跟你谈谈。
That was. You know, it was really with the pamphlets and people who didn't get their newspapers and stuff and all these years. And just a lot of like stuff. How dare you say stuff about pamphlets in front of Steve? I was like eight. I was like eight years old. Oh, is that guy top, top shelf?
那是。你知道，真的就是靠那些小册子，还有那些没收到报纸的人什么的，还有这些年来的种种。以及好多类似的东西。你怎么敢在史蒂夫面前说小册子的坏话？我当时大概八岁。我当时大概八岁。哦，那家伙是顶尖高手吗？
He really is. Man, man, man. Yeah. We didn't even talk about one of my favorite drama roles, but a beautiful boy with Timothy Shemily. No. I never saw that. Played his son who had an opioid addiction.
他真的是。天哪，天哪，天哪。是的。我们甚至没有谈到我最喜欢的戏剧角色之一，由蒂莫西·柴勒梅德主演的《美丽男孩》。没有。我从来没看过那个。扮演了他一个对阿片类药物成瘾的儿子。
Oh, man. I couldn't take it. It was almost, it felt like it was going to be too sad and I didn't want to watch it. It was. It was really, really good. I'm with you about the fox catcher. When I saw him, I was blown away. That was kind of amazing.
天哪。我简直受不了。感觉太悲伤了，我都不想看下去了。确实如此。真的非常非常精彩。关于《狐狸猎手》，我和你同感。当我看到他时，我惊呆了。那真是太神奇了。
Greg Frazier shot that too. Beautiful cinematography. So pretty. I loved when Jason asked if he cried at his wedding. He said, no, but I started sweating. And then Jason said, well, so your body was crying. I never heard that. Yeah.
那也是格雷格·弗雷泽（Greg Frazier）拍摄的。摄影太美了。非常漂亮。我很喜欢杰森问他结婚时有没有哭。他说，没有，但我开始出汗了。然后杰森说，嗯，所以你的身体在哭泣。我从来没听说过这个。是的。
Well, that's when the body is so wild. You're so nervous. The body says, and it starts crying when it comes out your pits. But it is kind of amazing. He's one of the few actors who really kind of crossed over from comedy to drama kind of seamlessly. You know, a lot of people, you know, when I was growing up, a lot of people wanted to be like Tom Hanks, like, oh my gosh, he was in all those comedies and then he's in all
嗯，人体就是这么神奇。你太紧张了。身体就会这样，当它从你的咯吱窝流出来时，它就开始哭了。但这确实挺神奇的。他是少数几个真正能够从喜剧完美转型到戏剧的演员之一。你知道，很多人，你知道的，我长大的时候，很多人都想成为汤姆·汉克斯那样的人，天哪，他演了那么多喜剧，然后又演了所有
these dramas. And it's so hard to do that. And Steve Carell is doing that. I think that, I think that Steve is people are by the way, both are both you have done that. And he hits it, you know, he made the point, which is that I think that people always go like, what is your plan and what were you trying to do? And a lot of people like, there is no grand plan.
这些戏剧。要做到这一点太难了。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔正在做到这一点。我认为，史蒂夫现在人们……顺便说一句，你们两个都做到了这一点。而且他把握得很好，你知道，他提出了一个观点，那就是我认为人们总是会问，你的计划是什么？你当时想做什么？很多人会说，根本没有什么宏伟的计划。
You just kind of go how you go and go with the flow and what happens to interest you at the time. Yeah. Well, like Mike Tyson said, everyone's got a plan till you get punched in the face. Yeah, I guess it's like that. I guess it's a little bit like that. Did he really say that? He did say that famously.
你只是顺其自然，随波逐流，去做当时感兴趣的事。是的。就像迈克·泰森说的，每个人都有计划，直到挨了一记老拳。是的，我想就是那样的。我想差不多就是那样。他真的说过这话吗？他确实说过，这很出名。
Yeah. Yeah, it's funny. Like every merchant said, forget who Mike Tyson was. So Mike, you seem to be in control very early. What was your plan going in or no, a vendor, I think it was a vendor hall of field. It seemed like you had a plan right up front there. And then that kind of went out the window. Were you responsible?
对。是的，挺逗的。就像每个记者都说，忘掉迈克·泰森是谁吧。迈克，你似乎很早就控制了局面。你进去时的计划是什么？或者没有？呃，是伊万德·霍利菲尔德（Evander Holyfield），我觉得。一开始你似乎有个计划。然后那个计划就泡汤了。你要负责吗？
Yeah. Yeah. Everyone's got a plan till you hit him in the mouth. You know, it's some version of that, but the thing of Tyson, first of all, he had those huge shoulders, but he had even bigger biceps, you guys, I guess that's the end of it then. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry and Rob Amjaref. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to
对。是的。每个人都有计划，直到嘴巴挨了一拳。你知道，大概就是这意思吧，不过泰森这人，首先，他有那么宽的肩膀，但他的二头肌更壮硕，伙计们，我想这期节目就到这里了。SmartLess 是由 Bennett Barbaco、Michael Grant Terry 和 Rob Amjaref 纯天然手工制作的。我们的下一期节目将在下周发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方收听，或者你也可以
it right now early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现在就在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过在苹果播客或 Wondry App 上订阅 Wondry Plus 来提前收听并享受无广告体验。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。